[Música]
hola y bienvenidos a nuestro último
programa de misión alfa donde durante
meses le estuvimos presentando un diario
en vídeo del astronauta francés thomas
que el pasado martes 9 de noviembre los
tripulantes de space ex regresaron a la
tierra tras una misión récord de seis
meses en la estación espacial
internacional la histórica misión fútbol
a bordo de la cápsula space ex dragon
llevó a cabo cientos de experimentos y
ayudó a mejorar los paneles solares de
la estación espacial internacional tras
un recorrido de ocho horas hacia la
tierra terminó con éxito una de las
mayores misiones espaciales de la
historia reciente nosotros hablamos con
pesqué y nos contó cómo fue el viaje de
regreso a la tierra es diferente la
experiencia de la reentrada atmosférica
es más o menos la misma quizás la
disfrutamos un poco más porque teníamos
ventanas más grandes vimos el plasma es
decir los gases ionizados por la
desaceleración el frío atmosférico el
calor se ponía todo rosado antes de que
las ventanas se pusieran muy calientes
es realmente espectacular los paracaídas
la desaceleración y el frenado son un
poco las mismas sensaciones
el amerizaje esta vez en el agua un poco
más suave que en la tierra con los retro
cohetes de la soyuz luego esperamos
tranquilamente que el barco viniera
recuerdos todo fue un placer toma cuando
se abrió la escotilla que fue lo primero
que lo sorprendió el olor el ruido creo
que los honores de hecho los chicos que
vienen a recogernos al todo un equipo de
rescate que viene a recoger nos pareció
que olían muy bien con la ropa y jabón
seguramente lo que eso quiere decir es
que nosotros no haríamos muy bien
después de haber pasado seis meses en la
estación es además de eso no estamos
seguros de nuestros movimientos incluso
ahora no podría correr 100 metros no
inmediatamente somos realmente criaturas
terrestres yo he tenido una suerte de
pasar en total más de un año en el
espacio que ahora es más bien un hábito
para mí pero realmente estamos hechos
para vivir aquí por lo que nos esperan
unas horas un poco difíciles a veces
unos días pero luego inmediatamente
recuperamos nuestro estado físico que
hacemos lo que hemos estado haciendo
desde siempre es que desde su llegada al
espacio el 24 de abril las actividades
de la tripulación incluyeron documentar
la superficie del planeta para así
registrar los cambios causados por el
hombre y también los eventos naturales
cultivar
hatch con el fin de estudiar la siembra
de productos alimenticios para misiones
espaciales de larga duración y
experimentos con gusanos para así
comprender mejor los cambios en la salud
humana en el espacio esto nos dijo toma
pesqué de lo que más resalta durante
estos seis meses en el espacio que de
alguna manera no he tenido mucho tiempo
para ver esa misión en retrospectiva
estaba concentradísimo pienso que
pasaron muchas cosas hicimos algunos
paseos espaciales que fueron
probablemente algunos de los más
espectaculares que he visto no sólo en
los que participé sino que he visto
fuimos hasta el extremo de la estación
para instalar paneles solares de 17
metros nos debemos tanto tiempo para
sentir las cosas movilizar en ellas
porque estamos muy metidos en el trabajo
creo que es como los deportistas solo
después nos tomaremos el tiempo para
mirar atrás y darnos cuenta pero creo
que es ese momento esa salida en
junio-julio y además el despegue y el
aterrizaje son grandes momentos la
adaptación de los astronautas en la
tierra es todo un proceso por ello
también hablamos con laura andrew boyer
su instructora física y nos con todos
los pasos que deberán hacer para así
hacer la adaptación más fácil del
astronauta en la gravedad de la tierra
veamos
necesitamos que el cuerpo se recupere
por sí mismo no debemos ayudarlo
demasiado porque queremos recoger esos
datos así que no vamos a intentar
compensar demasiado su sistema
cardiovascular por supuesto que no vamos
a dejar que sufras realmente no está
bien pero el principio de esta toma de
datos es permanecer lo más natural
posible durante las primeras horas y los
primeros días especialmente tendremos
que ver cómo se han desarrollado sus
ojos y tenemos que mirarlo enseguida es
súper importante que lo ayudemos de
inmediato así que los próximos días van
a ser largos y muy intensos la
experiencia del pez que debería
permitirle apuntar mucho más lejos que
la estación espacial internacional
hablamos de la luna el único satélite
natural de la tierra eeuu japón canadá y
europa están trabajando juntos para
poner en órbita la futura estación
alrededor de la luna no antes del año
2025 pero toma ya habla de ello con una
sonrisa
nunca ha habido europeos hay un puñado
de americanos que han estado en la
ciudad creo que lo emocionante del
proyecto que tenemos hoy de volver a la
luna no es sólo ir a plantar una bandera
pero realmente y por razones científicas
y también tener una presencia un poco
más permanente o por lo que de hecho
estaremos allá para ser exploradores
actualmente vamos a la estación espacial
internacional porque es el destino más
lejano de mañana en un destino más
lejano estaremos encantados de ir allí y
creo que esperamos estamos convencidos
de que será algo que le sirva a todo el
mundo no es solamente algo para nosotros
mismos para conseguir medallas y
palmaditas en la espalda sino que
estamos tratando de que sea útil para
todos creo que el resto de la aventura
continuará hasta que los dejamos con
estas imágenes de los mejores momentos
de pesqué en el espacio para mí ha sido
un gusto acompañarlos durante todo este
recorrido de ves que en el espacio hasta
una próxima oportunidad
[Música]